When I talked to people about doing the
future authoring program,
they often put it off and it's not
surprising because it's hard and and be,
but it's more than that.
They think,
well,
I don't know how to write.
I'm going to do a bad job.
I don't really like assignments.
I'm going to have to do it perfectly.
I need to wait until I have enough time
and like one of those is enough to stop
you cold and all five of them you're
just done.
And so I tell people do it haphazardly,
a tiny bit at a time and badly because
you can do that.
I tell my students when they're doing
their thesis master's thesis,
write a really bad first draft and then
we have a little conversation about that
because they don't think I mean that
because it sounds like a cliche in some
sense.
It's not a cliche.
It's not a cliche at all.
It means
you're a terrible writer,
but.
But if someone put a gun to your head
and said,
you have to have your a hundred page
thesis done by next Monday,
or I'll shoot you,
but I don't care how terrible it is,
you would sit down and write it,
and the thing is,
then you have it right then,
then you have something and then you can
fix it.
You can iterate and fix it.
That bad first draft.
That's the most valuable thing.
And so that's what you need.
You need a bad first draft of yourself
and there's.
There's an idea in the young developed
about the trickster and the gesture,
the comedian,
right?
That the trickster is the precursor to
the savior.
That's one of the things I learned from
young that was just.
It's so unlikely you'd never think that
it's so amazing that that might be the
case,
but the,
the,
the satirical in the erotic and the,
and the troublemaker that the comedian,
the fool,
the fool is the precursor to the savior.
Why?
Because you're a fool when you start
something new,
and so if you're not willing to be a
fool,
then you'll never start anything new,
and if you never started anything new,
then you won't develop.
And so the willingness to be a fool is
the precursor to transformation.
And that's the same as humility.
And so if you're going to write your
destiny,
you can do a bad first job.
You're gonna.
Get smarter as you move forward.
That's the thing is that so something
beckons to you.
That's what happens here.
Maybe the star that you pedal wished on
was the wrong damn star,
but at least it was a star,
right?
At least it was in the sky.
At least it moved him forward.
And so you say in your life or something
grips you and fills you with interest
and you think,
well,
should I do that?
And the answer is,
if not that,
then something.
What if it's a mistake?
It's a mistake.
Rest assured.
What do you know?
You're going to stumble around,
right?
And what's going to happen is this.
You're going to move to.
You're going to not stay in spaces,
you're not going to wander around in
circles,
and I see people like that.
They said,
well,
I never knew what to do,
and now I'm 40.
It's like that's not so good,
not so good,
and you might say,
well,
and there is literature to that suggests
that people are a lot more unhappy when
they look back in their lives about the
things they didn't do than they are
about the mistakes they made while they
were doing things,
and so that's really worth thinking
about too because there's redemptive
mistakes and a redemptive mistake would
be a mistake that you make when you go
out and try to do something.
You know you actually,
you think,
okay,
I'm going to try to do this.
When you're not good at it,
you make a bunch of mistakes.
It's like,
well,
what's the consequence if you pay
attention is you're not quite so stupid
anymore.
That's the thing is you've been informed
by your,
by the results of your errors,
and so what happens is you follow the
beacon,
you follow the light and you're blind so
you don't know where the light is.
It's dimly apprehended only and you're
afraid to follow it,
but you decided to take some stumbling
steps towards it and as you take
stumbling steps towards it,
you become illuminated and enlightened
and informed because of the nature of
your experience,
because you're pushing yourself beyond
where you are and you're going into the
country that you have not yet been in
and you learn something,
and so what happens then is the star
moves.
You move 10 feet towards it and you
think,
no,
that's not right.
I didn't get it right.
It isn't there.
It's actually there,
and so then you,
you see it somewhere else and you shift
yourself slightly and you move forward
and that's what happens is that
you continue as you changed the thing
that guides you forward,
moves,
right?
It's like God in the,
in the,
in the desert,
in Egypt,
the pillar of light that you're
following,
it's moving.
It's not a permanent thing.
You move towards it,
it moves away,
it guides you forward,
and so you say,
well,
is what I'm aiming at paradise itself,
and the answer to that is no,
because what do you know?
You see you couldn't see paradise if it
was right in front of you,
but you might get a glimmer of it and so
you move towards it and you grow and
then the next time you open your eyes
you see a little bit more clearly and
that's what happens is that just happens
over and over,
right?
It keeps moving
and so you move like this,
but the thing that's so cool is that all
those zigs and zags you say on each of
those Zags,
zigs is a catastrophe.
I hit a wall,
my God,
and then I had to die a little bit and I
barely got back up.
It's a phoenix transformation at each,
at each turn,
and it's painful,
but the thing is is that even though
you've.
You've traveled 20 miles,
let's say on that road and you've only
moved three miles forward,
you've moved three miles forward instead
of falling backwards.
Because that's the thing too is that if
you stand still,
you fall backwards.
You cannot stand still because the world
moves away from you.
If you stand still and there's no
spaces,
there's only backwards and so if you're
not moving backward,
back,
forwards,
then you're moving backwards and that's
more more of the underlying truth of the
matthew principle to those who
everything more will be given from those
who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
It's a warning.
Do not stay in one place.
Well as you zig and zag,
maybe the maybe the cataclysm of each
transformation starts to lessen.
There's not so much of you that has to
die with every mistake
and maybe you end up oriented at least
reasonably properly.
And if you were sensible,
that would have been your trip,
but it wasn't right.
It's that and perhaps it's a lot worse
than that.
Perhaps there's no shortage of
backtracking,
but it doesn't matter.
Because as you stumble forward,
you,
you illuminated and inform yourself.
And perhaps that's partly because the
world is made of information and if you
encounter it and tangle with it,
then it informs you and then you become
informed and then your information and
then you're ready.